what's happening there reject nation we
are going to watch arcane episode seven
today a pretty under the weather pretty
bad so if i look like i'm lower energy
that's only because i hate this show and
nothing to do with me feeling
obnoxiously sick right now but looking
over this shooting schedule there's just
no way we're gonna be able to have
thanksgiving off we don't film right now
so i got some medicines in me and we're
gonna sit back we're gonna enjoy the
hell out of this show
it's gonna be good i probably shouldn't
drink that that's like three days old
we're gonna sit here and we're gonna
enjoy it it's called the boy savior the
show's phenomenal
i can still pay attention to what's
going on so yeah
yeah
anywho let's make sure we can celebrate
thanksgiving
also remember to hit that like button
and subscribe click the notification
bell check us out on patreon thanks to
the boys of prepper all that jazz
[Music]
is this the jid verse from the theme
cool huh just as soon as you came clean
about what the hell you're really doing
down here i told you the truth [ __ ]
what was that glowing stone
that's what i thought
cool never seen it cut back and forth
between two different pov masks yeah
you shy or just ugly
a little bit of both shugley
you look good for a dead girl
who i'm not do i know are we supposed to
know who that is and i just don't know
if you're not stupid you guys want to
yell at me in the comments now i too am
stupid
is this a league of legends character
oh is it
oh the little kid the kid from um
not vander the other guy yeah yeah yeah
uh uh benzo yeah
i did it we're here well done
i mean you know he can cut us some slack
he's aged
he's got a new haircut
it's me vi same person who used to take
you down to the junk keep and hold you
down when you got covered in grease
people change
yeah
i'm getting that
are you working for silko
[ __ ] you
wow
i remember when you wouldn't stand up to
me
[Music]
bye
how long have you been whining
the subjects
wither and
wrought
perhaps the error resides not with your
calculations but with your [ __ ]
attitude your subjects okay
jace will understand
perhaps
damn jace is building an ironman suit
in a cave with a box of scraps
how'd you find me you're the de facto
head of the council people notice where
you go
don't remind me he is so buff i'll store
the council but they'll soon need their
leader
in the meantime
try not to lose your nuts
is that double entendre it's double
entendre i just lit with that man
where are you going i need to find jinx
sir
what
i have more in common with cave lice
than jinx
let's just say i didn't always see
eye-to-eye with my old man
she'll come to you
when she's ready it's weird cause him
and jinx have a sexual relationship
i'm just saying that
she was there for me not the enforcer
[Music]
oh
jeez
oh she's just some stupid top cider
yeah what the hell
stop oh oh my god you can go see someone
is that a real tree
pretty cool huh
when i first saw it i knew this was the
place wow
god that's beautiful i got one more
thing to show you
[Music]
memorial muriel your sister works for
him not because she has to
but because she wants to damn they even
put her on the wall that's who she is
now
you're wrong man she's still in there
just a little girl trapped inside of a
hot girl
i told you i knew someone well you
didn't say they were from the undercity
what difference does that make what
different they're dangerous
oh
you're right
i'm sorry he thought jace would be the
one who understands yeah
chase is letting the top side go to his
head
[Applause]
damn jace only been like two days
taking control and caused unrest
city-wide
rumor is you dogs are for leash
how are you meant to bring piltover to
heal if you can't handle your own people
huh
this guy like wants to die
i think he gonna get his wish
what's that
that heimerdinger let himself go
we came from a world where there was
never enough to go round
that is why we fight
do you remember
saliva
[Music]
good meeting
yeah for you
i feel like victor
this arrived for you
what is it it's a letter from her family
or something it's my guess but a part of
her still loves her family i know
maybe not for much longer
oh caitlin bad move let her go i brought
her here
it's me you want my hero
let me help you with that do the other
eye chasing down dead ends
and guess what
they're not all dead
i can explain
i might hurt you
i didn't know
marcus never told me she was in
stillwater
ah but you found out she came back
you lied
have you forgotten how she left you
who found you
who cared for you give you a home
i am your family
everyone else betrays us
so true right absolutely
you have to complete the weapon
[Music]
ah man she's so torn he's such a good
manipulator he can teach a class
this is my masterclass
your people hunt us
like animals silko pays them to do it
that's not possible you're wrong say
that one more time she's not your enemy
oh yeah then what's this
an enemy pin oh
that's our enemy identification card
membership badge
it's a gemstone
it was stolen during the attack
by your sister you just forgot to
mention that
with this
someone with the right knowledge could
build
any hextech device that includes you
we could beat soco with this
that won't solve things
easy for you to say your people aren't
dying all around you yeah you're not
under his grip at all times
this is our best shot at setting the
record straight
this city needs healing
more than i ever realized
kiss her
you got a plan
i have a friend on the council
let me take the gemstone to him
oh no not no no not him no
not jace please
i'm the one who gives it to them
that's even worse
we have the knowledge to defend
ourselves we agreed hextech was to
improve lives not not to take them we
may not have a choice
nice
that is always a choice
i need to think
[Music]
damn dude you're really losing sight of
yourself
oh
buddy
[Music]
i'm worried i have to do something i
never thought i would
[Music]
for when i was a little child
let's see what happens
[Music]
[Music]
ah that was a good
transition that happened before
it's been real cupcake
thanks
for everything
oh [ __ ] damn it she was just she was
just saying she's staying for you yes
now kiss her
kiss her so you prefer her over jinx
you're everything jinx couldn't be to me
what the hell is this
this [ __ ] i have proof silco's
behind everything
oh no
this [ __ ] not you
son of a [ __ ] dude
[Music]
life
no
i told you to leave this alone
looks like silko hires people
[Music]
oh
electric fire lights
[Laughter]
holy moly wow it's like maleficent
[Music]
thank god for that
what do all these conflicts end in big
explosions
don't mind
tell her everything i did to bring us to
this point
[Music]
[ __ ] hey
[Music]
what the [ __ ]
nice work dude
god damn it
oh
oh
oh my god wow
no
no
oh you two
nice
guys gorgeous
wow
no
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh man jinx
what the [ __ ] could he [ __ ]
hey have you're such a dick
[Music]
you better not be dead i know we're not
gonna get that cool animation anymore
of jinx she's not dead right she can't
be down she can't be but they i mean
they both they would have absolutely in
that explosion together
she's not that don't worry guys everyone
don't worry you probably already watched
next episode
well
i i'm a little speechless after that i
mean i know it's only the beginning of
act three
but each every each one of these
individual episodes has so much in it
and so much
stakes resonance uh you know harrowing
action
that uh
i'm always left a little dizzy
afterwards but especially as like the
break into act 3 for a show that's
already
rollicking and and you know filled to
the brim with
stakes and emotions and all sorts of
stuff like it really does feel like we
are cresting into you know sort of like
a a huge final confrontation between two
worlds so uh
yeah i was it's quite incredible
what would you think
uh yeah no that was amazing that was an
amazing ass episode i liked everything
about it
i thought that
uh is jace becoming a villain
i mean it seems like he's a possible
villain on that pat i wouldn't say
there's enough nuance that i wouldn't
just say villain but i can definitely
see him turning into an antagonist i
don't like getting caught up in theories
too much
so
i would say that
i think he's going to be right on the
verge of doing something really [ __ ]
up but somehow this experience of
victor's is going to pull him back to a
more grounded level
that's my failed prediction
that i'm getting out right now
so there's that
uh yeah no and i thought this whole
conflict that's happening with jinx
especially
just the center turmoil this
how torn she is on every account
what to believe who to believe and then
the negative thoughts in her mind that
manifests into these physical beings at
least in her perspective
how that overshadows it it just
kind of comes in and justifies its way
in
to any little thing that she can pick up
on to go look they're hugging that's
that's a sign she doesn't love you she
just wants she's only she chooses the
enforcer caitlyn over you
look at them hugging you know like the
littlest things she'll pick up on and
lose all sight of
context surrounding or not even try to
look into the context there's just it's
it's a fight for
it's a fight before powder and jinx
um
that's happening within them but i think
the biggest takeaway is probably all
that [ __ ] with echo
because his return
was awesome and i love the bookend of
that kind of crazy ass animation style
this
dazzling
expressive uh
art piece
on display
and uh so how does it work what was
happening there at the end he uses the
clock
or the um
what's that called what's up it's like a
yeah it's like a it's an old uh
i mean it's like kind of like a
stopwatch but it's like a yeah it's like
a pocket watch pogo watch
so he kind of sherlock holmes fights it
where he can sort of see
the
how this fight might go down and then he
uses that to his advantage of like i
would lose if i did it this way so let
me do this other way yeah
man that was that was tough that was
heartbreaking when he came to the port
where he was about to kill her i was
like oh man don't do it
i actually remember you guys kind of
getting along you two are really sweet
to each other
please don't do it so
yeah yeah that was tough that was a
rough one man yeah and it's like it's
the rare rare is the show
where like at the same time i'm like
being thrilled
being thrilled by action but also like
on the verge of crying or something you
know like this they're really good at
never really taking their foot off the
emotional pedal as they switch between
you know politics action
you know
machinations and whatnot
they they have
a special
grip on that particularly it's like
everything comes with expression and
feeling and emotion
no matter what it is
and uh yeah having him be the the leader
of the fire lights i thought was a
really uh nice
just sort of reveal and and the way that
they've shown you just how messy the
displacement of all these people has
been since they were kids you know after
this major conflict that sent them all
in different directions
you know and watching these uneasy
odds and alliances collide with each
other is really something special and i
mean this isn't a live action show so i
feel like it doesn't necessarily
count completely but i feel like this
has got to be the best
pound for pound video game adaptation
i've ever seen
just because i mean it's
it's so
cinematic it's so story and character
driven
but it makes me want to go find a league
of legends game and jump into that like
i'm like this world is is i want to jump
into the frame every time that they're
doing i mean maybe not uh you know get
suffocated by silko or something but you
know just the world
and everything about it is so alive
oh yeah
but you know who's not alive is marcus
that [ __ ] took the bullet
sucker
hell with that guy
i mean he made his bed
i don't feel any sympathy for him
whatsoever
he was a [ __ ] from day one
i don't know one good thing that guy did
uh yeah kind of
was one good thing i don't know why he
feels so sorry for him tried to not have
his daughter to die
by silko's oh wow
nature's he has a daughter and that's
the thing he did to be submitted not a
piece of [ __ ] it's good she wasn't
raised by that [ __ ]
she turned to a damn prostitute on the
streets that's right not like a good sex
worker like a really dangerous one a
dangerous path one who's also a serial
killer yeah it would have been awful man
you can't have a dad like that yeah i
have a doubt like that be awful yeah
setting examples of being in everyone's
pocket coward the orphans are the
coolest ones in this show absolutely be
like that
yeah i'm glad he's dead hated him
and uh
i don't know anything good about the guy
i don't know why this show tries to
paint it and sometimes in the light like
i should feel sorry i'm like why should
i feel sorry this guy's been an [ __ ]
i don't feel sorry for him but i pity
him
i guess
you don't have to agree with me
yeah
it's that line of i can
i can see
back to where you might have thought you
started with good intentions but pretty
much yeah i mean you're you're one of
the most unsympathetic characters in
terms of how your plight relates to your
actions
yeah
i love the development of caitlyn and
violet
so much man
especially this trust that she's been
earning and having to learn
the truth about the corruption within
her own society
especially like of course the person who
would show up is the
top of the corruption chain yes who
would just dick them over right away and
she's so blind to it you know
right away just hand it over show them
shown and bam
but the relationships develop with vibe
so strong like when they hugged i
thought that was such a touching moment
it was so touching
they'll love them together oh yeah do
they hook up they're going to hook up
guys
no anytime i make a prediction about
anything i'm [ __ ] wrong
tell me do they have do do they do it
there's no reason to suspect they rub
together what do they do guys
yes tell me if they do something yeah
actually don't we got two episodes
episode nine is just all scissoring
i hope so that's it
in that crazy animation style uh-huh
yeah with some imagine dragons playing
over see how it goes down first and she
goes i don't like those positions
yeah and then you know one of them does
some shimmer just to get things kinkier
yeah yeah it's gonna be good it's gonna
be good and then uh
what else happened in this episode john
i mean you got victor you got i mean you
got jace you know kind of disappearing
into his
status and all the varying you know
things he's expected to deal with as a
politician now and his rift growing with
victor that dude took a a big fall
a big fall
oh yeah to go from
aspiring science boy who wants to
influence the world and change it
to now torn between his political power
position and being a decent human being
[ __ ] man thankless
he was top priority should be helping
victor absolutely screw everyone else
victor's the big part of what's made
hextech work yeah it wouldn't have
happened without victor where's victor
doing right now where'd he go
i'm not sure i'll be i mean you know
he's he's definitely going undergoing
some transformation
between the shimmer and the blood magic
right right now that exchange there i
mean i
i'm fascinated to know what's going to
happen with him because i could enforce
each tragedy but i could also foresee
evolution in that
and uh i you know victor like even
though
you know he's uh
not he's a pretty prominent character
you know he's he's he's kind of a
supporting character if you look during
the overall and so on no the quite the
opposite i love him like unnecessary i
love him so much useless and i really
hope that um
yeah that's it that's right i really
hope he gets written off the show and i
really hope he dies they should just
recast chase is like i'm better off
without him yeah you know and then uh i
like victory guys just
no yeah i mean he's
i i really sympathize and i love the the
the choices they make like they're
really great at writing
[Music]
the characters in terms of
what
they're
sometimes when people withhold
information in shows it's really
frustrating because you know that there
could just be better drama going on if
you actually just got to it whereas here
you know i feel like it adds
to that and and their whole exchange on
the bridge you can kind of feel victor
reading jace and there's a reason he
doesn't tell him the true nature of
where he went and why
and uh
yeah i like how they keep it gray
because it's not just
chase what happened to you you you used
to be nicer
he doesn't just turn his back on him
even jace isn't like you're wrong victor
i'm right look how look how drunk with
power i've become
he he even catches himself being a
douche being like damn it victor you're
right i'm sorry how'd it go did it help
are you doing all right
damn it victor could have been lovers
it still could happen
yeah man you shimmer it up that's right
shimmer in the bedroom maybe that's the
keys the shimmer unlocks your whole
spectrum of loving attraction and then
mel got a letter and hybrid dingle nuts
he went to
he was i had a hood on at one point oh
yeah he's with the night he's going to
do something clandestine yeah
yeah he's going to strike back maybe
he's going to see the same guy victor
went to see maybe they're going to
reconcile and become future jason victor
or maybe he's like i've spent
thousands of years
working on science damn town i haven't
done anything fun
time to join a cult that's right he's
gonna join a sex cult it's time to go
out there and meet other beings like me
and
fornicate around town yeah yeah really
in a chance there's a spiritual time
i believe it it's hard for a guy of his
size to
and whatever species you he's a rat is
that it no a hamster he says yeah isn't
he a hamster or a rat or a cat i'm gonna
trust any conclusion you come to his
name's heimerdinger sounds like hamster
that is
yeah yeah the way he opened the bifrost
at the end man it's crazy yeah you have
that and then um
and then we're done with this video now
right we're done we've touched on
everything i think we talked about
everything touched on everything mel can
go to hell mel hell and jinx and silko
definitely gonna hook up oh dude yeah i
don't care what anyone says david no
they got some crazy they've gotten kinky
with that yeah you guys are [ __ ] all
you guys are like i don't see anything
sexual about the religion it was more
like a father daughter yeah okay
i want you to see a [ __ ]
half dress i see a
i see a father who like has a cut off
shirt all freaking intimate wrapping her
legs jumping on her dad he's laughing
like that at that age i'd be like
there's something [ __ ] weird going on
in that relationship face up on his neck
inches from his face seductively
i don't think they're actually doing
something i'm not saying that that's me
i'm not saying they're doing something
but i think if you saw that it shouldn't
happen you feel like there's something
kind of inappropriate about that
relationship i think there's something
at least outside of the normal
father-daughter parameters there
they're both deranged it's not out of
the possibility yeah i'm a possibility
no no i think they make you a little
uncomfortable with it yeah that's the
point i think that's the point
so no do i think they're hooking up no
is it a little bit intimately awkward
yes possessive yeah
yes
don't know why you would do that man
call this jinx type it in
i might have to delete some stuff out of
this video
once i find out how old they animated
her to be
she's 24 years old
jason
oh [ __ ]
so she's probably like nine
it says right there
jinx
it's only 10 to 15
guys i guess that's [ __ ] awkward as
[ __ ] you would not want a 10 to 15 year
old daughter doing that yeah i mean
she's got to be
she reads to me like a teenager to some
degree and then i get lost in the issue
like yeah if she's like 15 is she 18
is she a young 20
so when i said uh
powder is like a little girl trapped in
a hot girl's body
yeah you should retract that should that
be deleted
well you just shouldn't say it past this
point i mean if it was like a real
little girl that would be awkward that
would be very awkward yes if i was like
saying that about like
i don't know
leave me here in the channels i'd be
like yes that would be very right that's
really uncomfortable she's an actual
teenage actor she's really a teenager
playing a woman who's 7 000 years old
that's awkward yes you shouldn't say
that
but
they can literally
draw her
she's a drawing
getting
behaving in yes
very sensuous ways toward her mail
it's it's chopper it's done i'm canceled
i'm a pedo yeah
it's okay though here in the video
i just wouldn't cut it out i just
couldn't i just had to keep it in the
video it's all good it's all good it's
all good just don't say it past the
point we we were on record having
learned
that this is probably creepy so now just
yeah i think it holds great argument
towards them being [ __ ] disgusting
yes it does and it also
aids people saying that about me now
win-win
win-win silko loses
little girl lives fair trade
all right guys well
tell us
would you date jinx in three years
and would you generally behave like she
and silko do leave us great
daughters in here how intimate are you
with your father in your life
or your adoptive father
subscribe click the notifications
actually even more suspicious because
they're not actually father and daughter
so you're more likely to think there's
something weird going on here absolutely
and there's a lot of time spent with
other characters and not them so who
knows
who knows what silco gets up to you guys
are just so you guys just defend too
much you know that
you're disgusting human beings yeah
anyway tell us what you think about jinx
she's a drawing
like it's not a real girl
this is my way of protecting myself
i know haley steinfeld plays violet
ella pernell ah [ __ ] sounds like a young
person how old is she
you typed in ella fitzgerald in the
little dream of me is what he did i i
went to the first auto phil she is 25.
we're okay
the voice actress is well above age
we're okay guys awesome killing the game
[Music]
yeah all right well we're done hey
seinfeld she's also hot
and she is also an adult
but leah mchugh is not so don't say any
jokes
[Music]